meanwhile the rock and roll running
series returns to Las Vegas this weekend
Lots going on Runners going to be taking
over downtown on Saturday and then
they're going to be on the Strip on
Sunday which of course means closures
but first Laura negretti joining us live
from their health and fitness expo at
Resorts World good morning so have you
been doing your stretching Lauren you
ready yeah we we've been getting ready
here you know it's great we're getting
ready for work for leg day here for
warming up but uh you know I'm joined by
here by Chris Heisler one of the coaches
you know we live such a sedentary
lifestyle there's some things people can
do even from the comfort of their home
their own homes or you know in studio
right there John and Heather but what
are some tips here to to get moving
let's start with the basic questions
running a one-legged sport or two-legged
sport that's not two-legged that'd be
called jumping so running is a one leg
of sport because it at all times are on
one foot at a time so we sit all day one
of the best things you can do is stand
up on one leg see if you can just
balance on one leg for 10 15 seconds
once you're there then you can add a hip
swing to it so you come up almost like
you're going over a hurdle and every
time you're doing that that left hip
here is going to love you then you
switch challenge your kids hey can you
stand on one leg for 10 or 15 seconds
then you go over the hurdle back and
forth It's the best place to start warm
up your hips your glutes are gonna like
you once you're warmed up you come to
the Expo and you try to get 5000 steps
that's right that's a good challenge
right there 5000 steps yeah and then
come find me and we'll do a balance
challenge love that perfect well you're
depressed here here thanks so much for
the tips here as we get ready I hope you
guys are kind of going to practice that
if not in studio then on commercial
break for now live in Las Vegas Lauren
negrady8 news now back to you guys my
mind is blown it's a one-legged sport
we're doing some we're doing some maths
here acting like actually think about
that okay that was that was a good
tidbit